views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
i would categorize my mood as very
frustrated
tonight on politics now trouble on the
river more cuts announced on the
colorado bigger ones loom but states can
agree on what they'll be and
we have secure elections in nevada our
current secretary of state barbara
sugaski has done a phenomenal job a
discussion with democratic secretary of
state candidate cisco aguilar tweaks he
would make to nevada elections and the
business licensing process plus
this is just the last step on the run of
recovery from covet
we explore what southern nevada is
getting out of the newly passed
inflation reduction act
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
thank you very much for joining us i'm
john langler and we start with water
southern nevada's water chief is
frustrated with other states on the
colorado river who he says are not
taking conservation seriously it comes
after a federal shortage was declared on
the colorado river for a second straight
year lake mead and lake powell are both
about 27 percent full that means nevada
and arizona have their allotment from
lake mead cut even more nevada already
uses less than its allotment but the
department of interior asked all seven
states along the river to come up with a
way to cut their water use by an
additional 15 to 30 percent
the circumstances we face will require
swift actions and increased water
conservation in every state from every
sector
we all have a responsibility to ensure
that the water we do have available is
used with maximum efficiency and that
additional conservation will occur
expeditiously
nevada and arizona say they did put
forward a plan to do that however other
states rejected it critics say those
other states aren't taking the situation
seriously the i-team's george knapp
talked with southern nevada water
authority general manager john enzminger
about those next steps and what those
states need to do let's start this way
mr enzinger we saw your letter yesterday
in advance of the events of today and it
sure sounded like you were kind of
ticked off and disgusted am i
assessing that correctly
i would categorize my mood as very
frustrated
what went wrong at those meetings
uh not enough people taking the
situation seriously
are you not not willing to give up
anything at all
uh little to nothing
you've been no nevada's been warning
about this for a long time you have been
warning about this day for a long time
does it feel like judgment day has
finally arrived or at least the first
judgment day
well we didn't hear a whole lot of
judgment coming out of the federal
government
today so
unfortunately it feels like another day
going by without substantial progress
i saw a release from arizona water
officials they sound about as disgusted
as you um in the fact that other states
aren't getting hit with the same kind of
of uh sanctions i guess water sanctions
uh you used a phrase i forget what
the words you use
water profiteers or drought profiteers
what do you mean
well historically and even in the recent
past you know we saw water transactions
on this river for you know between two
and three hundred dollars an acre foot
and throughout this summer we've been
seeing agricultural districts propose uh
selling an acre foot of water for
between fifteen hundred and twenty three
hundred dollars so it's hard not to see
that as you know taking advantage of a
very dire situation you and i have
talked about this before for example
imperial valley we heard references by
these federal officials today about
certain agricultural uses imperial
valley where they're growing alfalfa to
export to china a very water intensive
crop we also know in arizona they grow a
lot of melons down there all of this
stuff taking place in the desert which
doesn't seem to make much sense does it
well ordinarily uh i stay out of my
neighbor's business but when you have a
math problem and 80 percent of the water
use is in agriculture and eighty percent
of that eighty percent is for forage
crops which are largely exported it's
hard not to see how that's not part of
the solution
nevada's in pretty good shape compared
to these other states because of
policies that your agency put into place
a lot of years ago
right
absolutely this situation isn't sneaking
up on us we've been preparing for 20
years for exactly this situation and
because of 20 years of conservation and
because of our investments in critical
infrastructure at lake mead we're going
to be okay even in a scenario where the
federal government can't release water
downstream to california arizona and
mexico so
you know yeah i want to be part of the
solution on the river but at the end of
the day
we're safe and secure even if the other
states don't take sufficient actions
now some of the things that drought
money could be used on includes
upgrading glen canyon dam and water
recycling programs like nevada's and
then using those programs in other
states
nevada senators catherine cortez masto
and jackie rosen sent a letter to the
department of interior this week and
they also asked other states to do their
part in the letter they say those other
states failed to help reach a deal on
the cuts on the colorado and the
senators urge them to act quickly and
adopt some of the suggestions laid out
by enslinger as you heard that includes
water recycling and again fixing glen
canyon dam
governor steve sisolak says if he wins
re-election he would take more steps to
protect in-state abortion providers and
out-of-state patients the governor's
already signed an executive order on
this which says nevada will not help
other states trying to prosecute women
who travel to nevada for an abortion for
that to become law though it would have
to go through the state legislature
sysolac's republican challenger as you
know is joe lombardo and he has
indicated he was overturned governor
sysolak executive order however he
hasn't firmly committed to doing that
yet
nevada's race for secretary of state
features a candidate who says the 2020
election was stolen that person is
republican jim marchant his democratic
opponent is cisco aguilar an attorney
for the andre agassi foundation this
week we spoke with him about why he is
running and elections
why run for secretary of state secretary
of state is an interesting position
because it has two main responsibilities
one is your regulator of elections and
two you are the administrator for
corporate filings as an attorney at
agassi managing the corporate filings
for the years that it was there
it's pretty difficult sometimes to use
that system and it makes me think about
all the small business owners in las
vegas that have to use the system on an
annual basis
and they shouldn't have to hire an
attorney to use that system it should be
logical it should be functional it
should be easy to use and understandable
but still get the information that the
state needs for a business to remain
compliant and then on the election side
you are a regulator you are supposed to
be a neutral person advocating for all
voters in nevada it's not whether you're
a republican or a democrat it's giving
access to every nevada and the
opportunity to exercise their voice and
to be heard
we'll talk about the election component
in a moment because there's a lot to
that but just getting back quickly to
the the business and the licensure and
all of that those aspects of the
secretary of state that office handles
i've used the website before you're
talking about business owners and the
challenges they deal with what would you
like to implement just to make it easier
and more user-friendly
to just do your business absolutely i
think it goes back to a statement my
contract professor made in law school he
goes don't ever try to overcomplicate a
contract use plain language people
understand because if people understand
it you're going to be able to get to a
point of agreement quicker than if
you're using fancy or technical language
that not everybody understands on a
daily basis i think if we review the
processes that are in the system now and
try to make a more logical i think
that'll make people happier let's switch
to elections it's gotten a lot of
attention recently for obvious reasons
allegations by republicans of fraud
challenges to the last
major election here back in 2020
some counties in the interim have moved
to hand counting most notably nye county
uh
should the legislature pass a rule to
prevent that in future elections and i
guess more importantly are you a fan of
this hand counting change
in nye county and others no i'm not and
there's specific reasons why i think
hand counting there's a reason why
automation exists one it goes to the
fiscal responsibility of it it's
efficient it's accurate
we have secure elections in nevada our
current secretary of state barbara
sugaski has done a phenomenal job of
ensuring our processes are secure
transparent and open and understanding
her perspective understanding why she
made the decisions she made is exactly
why i want to run for secretary of state
somebody needs to be in that position
that is neutral and understands that
this position is not about party it's
about the state of nevada and nevadans
who want to exercise their right to vote
so well your opponent in the race has
certainly made allegations repeated ones
that elections are rigged in nevada and
would implement changes of his own if he
were elected
what how do you convince voters that
they're not rigged i think it's twofold
one is understanding what the current
secretary has done to investigate every
instance of alleged fraud and her
conclusions on why there was no fraud or
fraud did not exist second is our court
system you know being an attorney i
believe in the rule of law i believe in
our court system and i believe that our
judges have acted in an impartial way to
say that fraud has not existed in our
election cycles
you can see more of our interview with
mr aguilar including why he is not
supporting voter id or ranked choice
voting proposals that's at 8newsnow.com
we have reached out to his opponent jim
marchant for an interview so far his
campaign has not responded to our
repeated requests
all right what's in it for southern
nevadans next on politics now we break
down what's in the recently signed
inflation reduction act including some
of that drought money we just referenced
plus electric vehicle tax credits but is
the cost of an electric vehicle still
too high stay tuned
remember those summers
that were just so perfectly
summer brian come on the people the
places those moments are still out there
i'm brian waiting to be found ready
brian summer won't last forever so make
the most of it during toyota's national
sales event right now get 1.9 apr for 48
months on a new 2022 camry or rav4 plus
every new toyota comes with toyota care
our no cost maintenance plan visit your
local toyota dealer today come in today
toyota let's go places
[Music]
detect this
living with hiv i learned i can stay
undetectable with fewer medicines that's
why i switched to devato devoto is for
some adults who are starting a hiv-1
treatment or replacing their current
hiv-1 regimen detect this
no other complete hiv pill uses fewer
medicines to help keep you undetectable
than devoto detect this
most hiv pills contain three or four
medicines devado is as effective with
just two
research shows people who take hiv
treatment as prescribed and get to and
stay undetectable can no longer transmit
hiv through sex don't take devoto if
you're allergic to its ingredients or if
you take to fetalide taking devato with
the petal eye can cause serious or
life-threatening side effects hepatitis
b can become harder to treat while on
devoto don't stop about it without
talking to your doctor as your hepatitis
b may worsen or become life threatening
serious or life-threatening side effects
can occur including allergic reactions
lactic acid buildup and liver problems
if you have a rash or other allergic
reaction symptoms stop tavato and get
medical help right away tell your doctor
if you have kidney or liver problems or
if you are may be or plan to be pregnant
davato may harm your unborn baby use
effective birth control while on novato
do not breastfeed while taking novato
most common side effects are headache
nausea diarrhea trouble sleeping
tiredness and anxiety detect this
i stay undetectable with fewer medicines
ask your doctor about switching to the
bottle
welcome back to politics now
president joe biden signed the inflation
reduction act into law on tuesday
democrats say will lower energy and
health care costs republicans oppose the
legislation they call it a tax and
spending spree natalie brandt takes a
closer look
president biden signed the inflation
reduction act into law tuesday calling
the mammoth climate health and tax
legislation historic let me say from the
start
with this law the american people won
and the special interests lost build as
the nation's biggest ever single climate
investment it directs nearly 400 billion
dollars in climate and energy programs
including tax credits and incentives to
cut emissions by roughly 40 percent over
the next eight years fred krupp of the
environmental defense fund says the
money comes at a crucial time we're at a
tipping point where the adoption of
electric cars electric trucks solar wind
power battery storage
is almost there but these incentives
will get us there with less than three
months to november's midterm elections
the president plans to hit the road in
the coming weeks to explain what's in
the landmark legislation democrats say
the new law will reduce costs for
seniors by expanding medicare's power to
negotiate the price of prescription
drugs though initially starting in 2026
affecting only 10 medications emotion is
adopted
the bill passed with no gop support
nonpartisan analysts say it's not likely
to do much to put a dent in the high
inflation americans have faced democrats
more than any other majority in history
are addicted to spending other people's
money
regardless
of what we as a country can afford
democrats say the legislation will pay
for itself and cut the federal deficit
by raising revenue through increased tax
enforcement and a 15 percent minimum
corporate tax natalie brand cbs news the
white house
all three of nevada's house democrats
and both democratic senators voted for
the bill congresswoman dina titus says
it will help southern nevada with water
and keeping drug prices down
how does this affect southern nevada
you know we're in the middle of a
1200 year drought
where the sunniest we're the hottest
we're the driest and so anything that
affects climate change is going to have
a super impact on us and it affects
people personally with tax breaks for
weatherizing their homes or for buying
electric cars but it also affects the
community by investing in projects along
the colorado river like recycling or
storage of water so that
we don't run out and you've seen those
bathtub rings out there second it helps
in the area of medical assistance
we have a high rate of uninsured in the
state
and now those that have obamacare will
they be able to continue their subsidies
for three more years and it allows
medicare to negotiate drugs because we
pay much higher prices for drugs than
any place else in
in europe for example so this will cap
your drug cost at two thousand dollars a
year and it will allow medicare to
negotiate with pharmaceutical companies
there are some taxes that are incur
included in this uh your opposition the
republicans are raising concerns you
know they're suggesting there's all this
inflation things are more expensive why
tax more nobody and all the pundits and
all of the researchers have confirmed
this and said that the republicans are
not telling the truth nobody who makes
under 400 000 a year is getting taxed
nobody the new taxes are on the big
corporations who make over a billion
dollars a year and these are
corporations who brag about not paying
taxes they're the ones who need to pay
their share and with the savings from
medicare
being able to negotiate drug prices this
is actually going to bring down the
deficit gradually over the next decade
so when you hear again some some of the
opposition raising concerns about for
example the extra irs agents that are
being hired and the concerns about
armed irs agents tracking down money and
all sorts of other
thoughts and and so forth obviously
you're familiar with those
what they're bringing up here uh
what is the reality of where the money
is going to go
well the reality is you are going to
hire more irs agents but they have been
tasked very specifically by the head of
treasury and by yellen that they will go
after those big corporations who can
hide that money billionaires who can
hide that money they're not going after
the individuals who've never been
audited to get little amounts of money
this is to go after those folks who have
not paid their share
congresswoman titus's republican
opponent in the upcoming election is
mark roberts in the colonel he says
america quoting here america needs less
spending not more we're dealing with
record inflation because of wasteful
spending in washington he continues the
dishonesty named inflation reduction act
dishonestly named won't do anything to
help americans struggling with the
weight of inflation
all right also included we talked about
electric vehicle tax credits is the cost
of an electric vehicle now still too
high that's coming up here on politics
now
nevada is suffering because of reckless
washington spending senator catherine
cortes masto voted to allow hundreds of
millions of dollars of covet relief
funds to be wasted on frivolous projects
not in nevada a luxury resort in florida
soccer stadium in new jersey skiing in
iowa a poet in connecticut french operas
in washington d.c we need help in nevada
not silly spending in other states tell
senator cortez masto to start voting
against wasteful spending to stop
inflation
this isn't your typical runaway ride
scene
it's a nissan sales vented
now that's something i can commit to
his rav4 doesn't even have as many
standard safety features as this rogue
now shop our inventory of certified
pre-owned vehicles love may be forever
but these offers are not
bad check fees credit card fees late
rent fees and those huge payday loan
fees don'tbepro.com can safely lend you
up to 5 000 in minutes to avoid those
fees no collateral and free to
[Music]
apply g
apply online adobebrogue.com
our desert summer heat can be deadly but
learning the warning signs of heat
stroke can save a life maybe your own
this 8 news now summer safety tip is
sponsored by landmark recovery
[Music]
best reviews is an unbiased team that
researches products in real world
situations to give reliable
recommendations on just about everything
for the best reviews go to
bestreviews.com
seriously before you buy anything ever
you're watching politics now
one of the main ways democrats plan to
cut emissions are with electric vehicle
tax credits they're for up to seventy
five hundred dollars on new cars and up
to four thousand dollars on used
electric cars
critics say the law won't give the ev
market the boost it needs because a lot
of cars won't qualify
transportation secretary pete
butterjudge says that's intentional
part of the design of this bill is not
to support any electric vehicle but to
support u.s made or north america made
electric vehicles
washington d.c correspondent alexander
limon joins us to break down the debate
over these tax credits
alex simone joining us from the
washington d.c bureau alex what are the
new parameters for cars to qualify for
these new ev tax credits
hey john well in addition to there being
limits on which cars can qualify for
these tax credits there are also limits
on who can qualify to get them and so
under the new rules that were passed by
the inflation reduction act vehicles
have caps as far as how much they can
cost so any sedans that cost up to 55
000 and suvs that cost up to 80 000 that
are all that are on that approved list
can qualify for the tax credits and they
also have to have the final
manufacturing um
in the us or i'm sorry in north america
actually so the final manufacturing has
to happen in north america in order for
the cars to qualify now as far as the
individuals uh individuals making up to
150 000 a year can qualify and for
couples who file jointly that's up to
three hundred thousand dollars a year
it's interesting and you also mentioned
there uh alex the cost of some electric
cars and they're pretty darn expensive
will this help make evs a little more
affordable
you know obviously that that's going to
be subjective and kind of depend on the
individual or the family but the list
that the uh biden administration put out
includes more than 30 vehicles that are
expected to qualify
and there is a wide range in the cost of
these vehicles and some of them are on
the much more affordable scale of things
when you add to that the tax credit
that's available again up to 7 500 for
new cars and up to four thousand for
used cars and definitely can put it
within reach uh for some people and some
families but what what is important to
keep in mind that on top of those
savings people actually do save a lot of
money on not having to pay for fuel so
right now
this year the average cost to charge an
electric vehicle at home per week again
this is on average is about 10 to 15
dollars a week there's certainly been
some criticism on this from the auto
industry from advocacy groups what are
they saying
yeah so for from the auto industry what
we've heard is that the great majority
of electric vehicles that are on the
market right now won't qualify for these
tax credits again the government put out
a list of about 30 cars or so that they
expect will qualify next year
and so there's a vast majority of cars
out there that won't qualify and the
administration says that's intentional
this tax credit is meant for again
vehicles that are manufactured in north
america and it's not meant to cover very
expensive luxury electric vehicles
and that was alex limon from washington
d.c nevada has also been working on
adding charging station there's the
so-called electric highway being
constructed between las vegas and reno
will nevada's youth show up in the
upcoming election we'll have a new look
at the growing number of 20-somethings
becoming politically engaged on politics
now findlay automotive began with one
dealership in 1961. today we have 18
locations across the vegas valley we
have more cars trucks and suvs than any
other dealer group in nevada no matter
where you are in the valley you're never
far from findlay
knock knock who's there
adam laxalt adam laxalt who it's adam
laxalt who was caught calling roe versus
wade a joke rugby wave was always a joke
as nevada's attorney general laxalt
signed onto multiple efforts to restrict
abortion access and he's made it clear
he wants to make abortion illegal having
adam laxalt represent nevada there's
nothing funny about that i'm catherine
cortez masto and i approve this message
we're the lifelong local and we're the
welcome wagon in 1972 we saw our very
first patient ever since we've been
expanding our services locations and our
team to bring quality healthcare to you
our neighbors
for 50 years we've called las vegas home
and we couldn't be prouder
thank you for trusting us with your
health southwest medical 50 years of
community care
you're a champion of multiple fantasy
leagues your dominant reign is
unprecedented to watch over this
dynastic empire you scored a tv that's
unbeatable in every measurable visual
category
the only thing that can hand this fancy
tv a bitter defeat
internet from the wrong provider
you could have gotten cox internet with
america's fastest internet download
speeds because good things deserve good
internet
findlay automotive began with one
dealership in 1961. today we have 18
locations across the vegas valley we
have more cars trucks and suvs than any
other dealer group in nevada no matter
where you are in the valley you're never
far from findlay
you're watching politics now
the justice department has asked to file
a redact it has been asked to file a
redacted version of the affidavit which
allowed the fbi inside the former
president trump's home last week a
federal magistrate judge is giving the
doj a week to propose those redactions
this comes after attorneys representing
news organizations asked a judge to make
parts of that document public the
justice department says making the
document public could compromise its
investigation into former president
trump
a non-profit says more youth in nevada
are registered to vote circle from tufts
university in the northeast says the
number of people aged 18 to 24
registered to vote here is 28 percent
higher than it was four years ago
since 2020 it's 20 percent higher it
also ranked the nevada senate race as
the third most likely race to be
impacted by the youth vote
nasa is continuing to commit resources
to studying ufos a report from space.com
says the agency will go full force into
those investigations
nasa says its main goals are to lay out
the best ways to collect observations in
the future
the agency also wants to figure out how
to advance our understanding of these
sightings space.com reports the study
will begin in the fall should last about
nine months
that will do it for us here on politics
now we thank you so much for joining us
this week stay up to date online with
all the political news by going to
eightnewsnow.com and you can join us
here every saturday thank you for
watching have a good weekend
[Music]
you